[Music]
hey what is up guys umhd here and this
is the red
oneplus 6. so it's the oneplus 6 it's
everything you already know and love
about it we've already reviewed it but
the back is now this bright
vibrant
deep reflective
red
and uh
that's
it
that's it everything else about the
phone is the same but it's now red it's
a red version of the phone we already
know that we
okay
here's the thing about colored
smartphones
[Music]
i love them but i also kind of hate them
the way they exist and and a whole lot
of these thoughts are already kind of
floating around out there in these
various chunks and bites on twitter and
even in previous videos but it's worth
putting it all in one place so this red
one plus six dropped pretty recently and
when i didn't put a video out right away
about it there's like a couple comments
and tweets here and there just like hey
the red one like i thought this would be
the one you'd love to make a video on
where's your video and to be honest i
was thinking about it i was thinking of
reviewing it but then i was like it's
the same phone it's the oneplus 6 i
already reviewed it you already know
everything about it it's just the new
red color maybe just a photo at best but
then i double back on that and here we
are with a video why first of all you're
right i do love red i love that they
made a red smartphone and so now i'm
sharing it with you because that's what
i want to do but also i just want to
talk for a second to you about colored
phones in general so there's this really
interesting video published recently of
a bunch of potential alternate colors
for the oneplus 6 on pc mag one of them
included a colored alert slider i would
have loved to have seen that uh but then
there was also some more interesting
colors this speckled one there's a wavy
striped one and even this instagram one
shout out to igtv and so the natural
reaction when seeing all these colors
that they could have done or that they
were thinking about doing is why didn't
they just do a bunch of these why didn't
they drop all of these right at launch
that would have been awesome well the
answer is twofold number one companies
generally would like to sell as few
variations of a single product as
possible as few skus as they can so if a
company could sell all their phones in
one color and one storage amount they
would that's why i see car companies
like bundling as many things as possible
into one option package is because they
don't want to have 75 different ways
they can make their car they just want
to make one so if you're a smartphone
company and you can just sell black and
white and maybe one other color then
that's what they'll do but the number
two answer right now is also that
smartphone companies are using alternate
colors as a press tool basically to
remind you about a smartphone that
already came out so there's something
you can call a press cycle every time a
new phone comes out there's a pretty
predictable spike of attention at the
beginning the height of sales and then
it sort of falls off in this long tail
as the device gets older maybe a drop in
price might bump it up again but for the
most part it'll never get that much
attention again but releasing a brand
new color of the same exact phone and
delaying it a couple months after that
release is obviously stirring up a brand
new press cycle it creates a new wave of
videos a new wave of articles brings a
little attention back to the phone and
at the end of the day we'll boost sales
oneplus does it samsung does it apple
does it almost everyone almost
everyone's guilty at some point of doing
this this special edition late release
smartphone and if you pay careful
attention to the way
apple does it
they specifically use new alternate
colors when a new product has the same
design or like the spec bump on the
inside so when they went from iphone 6
to iphone 6s the design of the phone was
exactly the same there's just a spec
bump like apple does so they added a
rose gold color so now you can tell who
has the new iphone you can't get the
iphone 6 in rose gold so you know that's
the new one and then when they went to
iphone 7 the design again was super
similar so we got this jet black version
so you can't get a jet black iphone 6 or
6s so you know that's the 7. even with
the new apple watch when they came out
with a new lte version they painted a
big red dot on the crown so you know
that person must have the new lte
version of the watch truly classic apple
and then this year rumors point to the
fact that there won't be a huge design
change with the next iphone 11 or
whatever they call it from the iphone 10
so same design maybe new sizes
but with that they're going to do new
colors so we've got these rumors of a
blue color and an orange color and a red
color to all launch with the new iphone
so you know you have the new one and the
thing is
i'm still pumped for it anyway like i
love it and i hate it i love it because
colored phones are actually really
exciting they look really cool
they're unique they're kind of personal
and everyone does it differently to make
themselves stand out there's about eight
or nine different red phone finishes
that have come out in the past couple
years and every single one of them has
different looks different hues different
reflectiveness different color shifting
my personal favorite i would say is
apple's product red probably followed
closely by oneplus new one and then
believe it or not the blackberry
passport in red but i'm so into all
these colored phones but i hate it
because i know it plays exactly
perfectly into the manufacturer's hands
they're gonna release a new alternate
color of this phone that they could have
probably released on day one but it's
gonna generate this new batch of
coverage and all these new videos and
articles and probably new sales now to
be fair i love what apple does with the
product red stuff not only with the
phones but with the cases and all that
stuff where they're working with a great
organization they're donating to aids
research i think more companies should
do stuff like this but the fact that the
phone comes out six months after the
original every time in red is pretty
hilarious at the end of the day though
i'm not gonna stop covering colored
phones in fact i'm gonna cross my
fingers for more of them i hope we get
all those new colored iphones i hope we
get all these new custom phones i missed
moto maker back in the days when you
could customize every little thing from
the material to the back of the phone to
the button colors and all of that that
was peak smartphone customization in my
opinion and that's where i want it to be
but until then i'll just keep crossing
my fingers
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching
peace